los actos de campaña oficiales
terminaron en efecto el viernes pero hoy
sábados realizan unos pequeños actos de
campaña sobre todo en los inscritos
electorales de los principales
candidatos de sucederá en miram el que
estamos hablando en particular de abril
a cesc de la cantidad del propio
conservador y de olaf scholz el
candidato socialdemócrata en el caso
particular de admiración por ejemplo el
de nuevo recurrió a la figura de angela
meter a la compañía de la canciller a la
espera de que es una ayuda para revertir
parte del mal momento que tuvo en las
últimas semanas y darle ese empujón de
cara a las elecciones de este domingo y
esta es la diferencia entre los dos
partidos sigue siendo muy muy baja según
las últimas encuestas incluso la
diferencia es de un punto porcentual lo
que significa que la carrera para
suceder a merkel de verdad continúa
abierta y es imposible predecir a esta
hora exactamente qué pasará el domingo
en las elecciones